[Musique]
rouler au témiscamingue
c'est bien différent que de rouler en
abitibi ici il n'ya pas de mine mais des
paysages vallonnés eu de terres
agricoles qui rappelle les stries pas de
forêt boréale non plus mais une forêt
mixte qui rappelle les laurentides le
témiscamingue est une vaste région
méconnue du québec
habité par seulement quinze mille six
cents personnes
totu de 1.2 kg mais habitant
philippe barrette 89 ans est une
encyclopédie régionales il a travaillé
toute sa vie dans l'industrie forestière
à témiscamingue sont va pas eu la peau
du jeune qui est qu'elle continue ici
l'ancienne papetière tembec
aujourd'hui rien venir et la plus grosse
usine de la région
ses deux fils qui ont pris la relève
contrairement à tant d'autres jeunes qui
partent étudier ailleurs pour ne plus
revenir
mais free sont ingénieurs ils disent
qu'en valeur certaine difficulté à
recruter du personnel qualifié
pour maints s'établir dans nos milieux
le vieillissement de la population
ça nous appauvrit au cours des 25
dernières années la population du
témiscamingue a diminué de 14% et selon
l'institut de la statistique du québec
la région risquent d'avoir 8% - de
résidents en 2041
reste qu'un habitant sur quatre à plus
de 65 ans aujourd'hui une heure de route
plus au nord la petite municipalité de
fugères ville paraît figé dans le temps
au milieu du village l'école primaire
abandonné a été fermée en 2019 et 75
ares et est conçu dans un coin de sa
maison à l'eau et j'y suis encore
l'agriculteur coloré le maire fait
partie des 326 personnes qui vivent ici
entouré de terres agricoles les avalats
c'est une richesse et blanc lui aussi
nous parle du déclin de son coin de pays
c'est pas une évolution c'est de la
récession l'agriculture garde le cuir
weiler pense qu'il reste quatre cinq
agriculteurs qui a dit qu'ils possèdent
1015a du village de teir alors à ce
moment là c'est pas du monde que la lega
veut dire maison le tout ces sociétaires
là présentement il ya plus de maisons
les gens choisissent de partir pourquoi
ipad parce que parce que lyon la route
quelques-uns fut gervais l'état sept
heures de route de montréal et à cinq
heures de route d'ottawa et de toronto
le témiscamingue est isolé et aucune
autoroute ne s'y rend un enjeu de taille
pour la région qui souhaitent se
développer et être découvertes dans ce
contexte l'ouverture du tout dernier
parc national de la sépaq en 2018 le
parc au pemmican symbolise le renouveau
de la région le lui nous ramène à
l'histoire des autochtones et des
draveurs sur l'immense lac témiscamingue
mais surtout il fait découvrir 252 km
carrés de nature quasi intacte on a un
territoire énorme où on va pouvoir se
retrouver seul sur des lacs où on va se
retrouver justement dans les grandes
forêts pain blanc comme on voit le site
implanté un rouge
le parc a été créé grâce aux démarches
de thémis camier et ici tout le monde en
parle en 2020 son achalandage a été 40 %
plus élevé que prévu ce qui nous
enchante nous c'est que les gens
viennent et revient déjà et le mont se
passe beaucoup ça fait une traînée de
poudre notamment au niveau de l'ontario
c'est un parent comme nous au public 1
35 million visite ça représente entre 1
et 2 millions de retombées au niveau de
la région simplement avec ce qu'ont eu
comme clientèle les nids de l'année
dernière des fois il faut une semaine
l'intéressé en noir lui remonté à ce
qu'on a
il est pur soit intéressante de mammon
on est à fort potentiel le tourisme
nouveau fer de lance du témiscamingue et
attention ne dites surtout pas ici que
vous êtes en abitibi ça allait séparer
on va être connu
c'est devenu les gens qui me connaissent
c'est devenu une blague quand quelqu'un
dit on est allés chez moi un habitué des
mots super temps vous êtes connu chez
nous parce que chez elle dit la préfète
qu'il fait plus chaud qu'en abitibi il y
à 7500 lacs et rivières et le paysage
n'est pas plat quand vous arrivez ici au
témiscamingue la distance ça valait la
peine va parcourir quand on voit le
paysage si les gens découvrent le
témiscamingue l'apprécient et continuent
d'y venir
certains services vont augmenter vont se
bonifier vont on voit offrir de plus en
plus de ces services là il est vrai que
l'offre en hébergement et en
restauration est assez limité
aujourd'hui mais l'agro tourisme se
développe ici avec d'autres marie hélène
l'esa a ouvert sa fromagerie il y à 25
ans cache agressive team sky j'avais
vraiment le sentiment que tout était
possible que toutefois que tout était à
faire
si tu maintenant ça a été facile mais
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
mais ce n'est pas le seul dans mon kolda
elle fait maintenant travailler une
vingtaine de personnes et quelques-uns
de ses fromages se vend dans tout le
québec
elle aussi est bien décidé à faire
connaître sa région des fois les japon
alors qu'ils ont l'impression qu'on est
dans tout et en tabarnouche mais on n 11
de belles régions agricoles avec autre
chose que des champs de maïs à voir
[Musique]
les autochtones qui représente 28 % de
la population participe aussi à la
relance
what i c est le chef de la nation québec
lines demand nous a montré les travaux
d'une nouvelle marina accessible à tous
sur le lac kipawa au coeur de la réserve
le projet comprendra des quais mais
aussi des kiosques pour exposants et un
nouveau centre culturel nous avons
décidé de faire l'économique belle-mère
pour améliorer la situation de la
communauté et beaucoup de gens à part un
beau vision des réserves mais aurait
pour nous à les algonquins c'est une
chance de mettre en avant notre culture
pour tout les québécois pour tout les
touristes qui vient à la région nous
avons comme un trait principal la nature
en partenariat avec tourisme kipawa la
première nation qui y participent aussi
à une vidéo promotionnelle pour attirer
les visiteurs
le témiscamingue se donne donc un bel
élan mais le tourisme et surtout une
solution pour l'été il ne réglera pas
tous les problèmes démographiques
on a besoin que les mêmes la préfète a
vu ses quatre enfants quitter la région
est ce que ça vous ferait quelque chose
ça me fait beaucoup de peine et je
constate que les enfants quand ils sont
partis ils s'en allaient aux études
or ici on veut développer des services
d'études collégiales et d'études
universitaires ça aiderait beaucoup
en attendant tous été miss camier
rencontre et invite québécois et
ontariens à venir les rejoindre
navy va te restera une des maisons font
sens mais 120 adhérents qui vient de
chez le ch et veulent travailler le
plein emploi
ensuite travaillé à 4h30 à 16h40 qu'on
est chez nous il ya cinq ans - quand on
est sur le lac en train de pêcher notre
cité je pense que le monde sont très
accueillants
si la secret le mieux gardé du québec
auprès les dames passionnées sympathique
ils sont comme leur région à découvrir